I tremendously enjoyed this because I
love stories where it would seem crazy
if you tried to write this as fiction
but it's that much more incredible
because it's true and real so Jensen as
someone who was a Formula 1 driver who
was in the middle of all of this and who
won the 2009 World Championship what did
you most love about your experience is
it something you can even sum up in that
way in in
2009 yeah just like when in the middle
of all of this
Insanity it's a funny one
because you know I I watched the
documentary and it's it's so special to
to to to follow what we achieved that
year the highs the
lows but when you're living in it it was
stressful it really was you know the
emotion and the pressure you put
yourself under um it moments that year I
was it probably at my lowest which you'd
think how's that possible you know
you're leading a world championship
because I led every race in terms of the
world championship but the pressure gets
to you it's
tough um but winning the championship
the way that we did in
Brazil that made it all better you know
the high that we had there was just
extraordinary um and you know winning a
world championship that's something that
lives with you forever they never they
can never take that
away uh so every time I get to think
about that season puts a big smile on my
face and that was one thing that was
great about this documentary I was able
to stop and look back at what we had
achieved that year time's moved on 14
years we've all moved on doing different
things but I could stop and look back so
I thank you Keanu for giving me that
opportunity thank you Jackson well Keanu
why do you love Formula 1 why do you
think it's worth this documentary what
is it about it for you I don't know
those cars look cool yeah they sound
freaking awesome and racing is neat it's
NE it's fun it's like it's Primal it's
it's a team but it's also solo it's like
the outfits are
cool um it's very unique it's very
special not everyone can do it you know
actually no one can really do it except
for a b a couple of people yeah um it's
glamorous it's exciting it's um and I
love stories and so to be able to have
the generosity of so many people to
share their experience of a of a of I
don't know if there's ever been a year
like in Formula 1 like 2009 you know a
financial crisis rule changes so new
cars um inter Nene Warfare between you
know the teams against the the the
commercial rights holder and burn like
it might be collaps it might be the last
year of Formula 1 like what's going on
and then this team Ross Brun a genius
joining this other team Nick fry trying
to like I mean Jensen you drove a car in
a in a Shakedown that had no
sponsorship you drove like a white car
with like no sponsorship they weren't in
the brochure for the first race in
Melbourne like they didn't know that
they'd be racing like oh my gosh you see
that we we even got the wrong numbers in
the garage that I didn't see that oh
really right it's number 20 and 21 on
the wall and we were 22 and
23 I mean what's going it's like it's a
bad news bear it's a team that
can't but it's a team that did and it's
how K how do you find the experience of
being the one sitting in the chair
across from the subjects asking the
questions did your own experience with
being the subject of interviews yourself
shape or dictate at all the way you
wanted to handle this um yeah sure the
experience of what is a good interview
or bad I mean it's it's as you know it
could take so many different shapes you
know but um you know I I I really enjoy
interviewing people I mean I love
conversation and I love you know kind of
getting to know the how's the why's the
where's you know as an actor you're
always investigating your character the
story um so I really enjoy sitting down
and having a conversation with someone
about what they do and did J for you I
mean do you feel like you are someone
who thrives Under Pressure do you feel
it all before you get in the car and
start the race or do you feel it until
the race ends I think that moment in my
career when I was
29 I struggled Under Pressure I put
myself under immense pressure after that
season season I grew so much as a driver
physically mentally and I put good use
over the next few years when I had LS
Hamilton probably the greatest ever
Formula One driver as my
teammate um but that season no I
struggled under pressure when I had a
good car and I was at my best I was
unbeatable but as soon as that dropped
away I struggled with it and uh I don't
mind saying that
and I was afraid to show a weakness I
think as a racing driver this is very
you know an aggressive sport where we're
very strong and and you don't want to
show weakness you don't want to show it
to your
competitors but I think if I did I would
have got over the slump a lot quicker
but it wouldn't have made such a good
story would it so the way it played out
it's perfect but in the moment it
definitely didn't feel perfect Keanu as
as an actor who has done a good amount
of physical stunt work and you are
someone who is a racing Enthusiast does
it feel like one sort of feeds into the
other as far as you're interested in it
and then it feeds back like are you
interested in doing physical work
because you love racing and does the
interest from racing come from that I
mean it it just it feels like they're
very natural companions I don't know
maybe the I don't know about the
competitive aspect of it but
um I think you're they're both very
physical you know moving through space
understanding your own
space um and also there is a discipline
there is
training um skills different skills uh
and you have toal and a lot of
evaluation like you do something and
then it's like what did I do and then
how can I do it better yeah you
know I think that Jensen when you agree
there's some in there with a Race Car
Driver
I I no I I feel that certain actors
could be amazing well they definitely
have the right mindset to be great
racing drivers because they're they're
all about the fine detail um studying um
and trying to make it their own
and you know obviously you need the the
natural ability to be able to turn a
steering
wheel and drive around corners but I
think yeah I think I think I think Keanu
could be a great racing drive though
that's very kind of you sir and I look
forward to your performance on stage is
H I tell you what it definitely doesn't
work both
ways the worst actor really am well
thank you guys so much thank you for
interesting me in in this whole subject
I was fascinated with the series so
thank you so much oh great thank you
thank
you